nous allons maintenant rejoindre la page
cinéma avec gérard lanvin et jacques
villeret pour le film d'hervé palud les
frères pétard
un film dont on va beaucoup parler d qui
a un petit peu défrayé la chronique à
cause de problèmes de censure nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure mais
apparemment je voudrais vous donner une
bonne nouvelle c'est une nouvelle qui
concerne l'antenne de notre chaîne
puisque à partir de la mi novembre les
téléspectateurs britanniques ma chère
france pourront voir en soirée sur
channel fort la grande série l'antenne
de châteauvallon et une diffusion en
version originale sous titrée ce est
également prévue dans l'est dans
l'après-midi ce qui permettra aux petits
anglais d'apprendre le français par
l'intermédiaire d'une production
typiquement française qui est pas mal et
parme à la safra catz owen est peut-être
ce n'est pas marqué là mais il parlait
très très bien l'anglais pour sa venue
moi tout ça alors messieurs ses frères
pétard vous êtes bien amusé pour le
tourner parce qu'il paraît qu'on s'amuse
bien là la projection tout cas oui c'est
d'ailleurs commencé mais on s'amuse
toujours une projection à partir du
moment où les gens qu'on fait des films
se sont amusés à les faire c'est une
question de vibrations alors nous on
s'est vraiment amusé à le faire et mardi
soir au rex je pense que c'est à celle
projection là vous faites allusion dire
avec autant d'invités venus gentiment
nous voir dire il s'est passé un truc
formidable quoi alors c'est la première
fois que vous tourniez ensemble g
d'huile de riz gérard lanvin ou pas on
avait toujours une fois mais une scène
dans
film de claude zidi qui s'appelait bête
l'indiscipliné mais c'était une
rencontre très brève oui et là ça s'est
bien passé semble-t-il entre vous deux
je comprends qu'ils aient gérard
effectivement je prolongeais beaucoup
amusé et partant de là on s'est dit mais
des chances de musées les gens je crois
qu'il ya ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
résultat nous est rejoint dans l'humour
alors que vous trajets sont un petit peu
différent vous gérez vous venez plutôt
de l'école du splendid
quant à vous jacquou vous avez toujours
fait un petit peu cavalier seul vous
avez fait des one man show où il allait
sans doute à refaire pour je suis des
chemins traditionnels enfin l'important
c'est de s'être trouvé la mort je crois
que c'est l'humour c'est c'est pas des
choses qu'on apprend il n'y a pas des
formes d'humour il ya l'humour et à
partir du moment où on a l'intention de
se marier ensemble entre acteurs en
en général ça rappe pas quoi alors
france est un film qui est un film de
société et comme dirait les sociologues
mais qui lui permet de s'amuser sur les
problèmes n'est justement maintenant de
plus en plus on fait des comédies sur
des problèmes de société ce qui est bien
normal puisque volière faisait des
comédies sont des problèmes de société
on va voir par exemple dans le prochain
film de francis veber un chômeur qui en
est réduit au bout du rouleau à
commettre un hold up et en prendre une
otage
on verra dans y at il quelqu'un pour
tuer ma femme l'espoir d'un kidnapping
et là en effet on voit l'histoire de
deux petits d'hilaire d'occasions parce
qu'au fond ils ont été embringuée dans
une histoire de drogue on les a faits
promener avec de la marijuana et il se
trouve obligée de négocier puisque c'est
leur salaire mais c'est bien mieux quand
même que les histoires de belle-mère et
d'adultère qui datent sg 1900 à l'effet
devrait qu'henri beaucoup parce qu'on
rit beaucoup plus des choses qu'on
connaît nationale est un petit peu ça
pendant quelques minutes avec un extrait
les frères pétard
haget
et
6 à la fin étant portée directe au
boulot et je me mets là haut dans tout
le quartier
mais j'ai plus creux voir chez moi tu
prends tes affaires et quittera dès ce
soir
puis la commune air tu me les gonfler
les malheurs je suis pas l'abbé pierre
moins savants ta poche histoire je peux
prolonger je suis complètement à huy où
ça ou ça à tout bleu
à l'accord et et elle n'est pas terrible
la fia geronimo a passé le style de
meubles qui me fait craquer comme
propice quote je vais la démonter mais
du moins s'il veut bien tout un puits
durant j'étais à peine autant l'être la
semaine dernière on a repêché sa brosse
à dents dans le cassoulet évitons ça un
an mais ça c'est les cuisines qui m'ont
fait une blague c'est ça oui bah ouais
et lui il arrête de rigoler lui il se
fout de ma gueule mais évitons ça aussi
bourg il est nu et manu dis moi même si
je peux pas dormir ici qui peut pas me
des paniers de chroniqueuse peut être
donc toujours un fond pour faire un
fanta pas de bol sur ed donc tu peux
qu'être lepers une bourde quand même non
certes toi mon pote jean à lanvin vous
être gardé pratiquement aucun moment
vous n'aimez pas vous revoir
c'est monsieur assez vu dans ce film là
je me suis assez vu je voudrais passer à
autre chose non
pourquoi il est fait beaucoup de prises
à chaque fois non non c'est pas ça parce
que le film moi j'y participe de a à z
et à partir du moment où on y participe
de a à z
il est bien évident qu'on participe au
montage du film qu'on participe au
mixage à la musique etc etc on le voit
fréquemment et donc à un moment on le
connaît par coeur on sait assez alors ça
veut dire quoi
peters je crois que c'est une expression
de largo dans la drogue s'y coller d'un
gros choix voilà c'est une association
der magie toutes ces aides que fumer
dans tous les we stern les indiens
volume et de la presse c'était des
pétards dans j p il fait bon là c'est
dans du papier à rouler la sig à rennes
et c'est par rapport à la forme on a
bien observé dans marche à l'ombre
puisqu'il y avait aussi un gros pétard
dans marche à rome c'est ça vient du
fait que la forme de la cigarette en
question a une ressemblance ou un pétard
c'est alors dans tous les dossiers de
presse que nous recevons nous les
journalistes vous insistez beaucoup sur
la notion de famille avec christian
fechner qui a qui a produit ce film
d'après ce que vous dites tout ce que
vous entendez très bien et vous avez
l'intention de continuer à bosser
ensemble c'est que je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de choses en commun
c'est-à-dire une envie de faire des
films qui soit spectaculaire en tout cas
qui sont du divertissement avant tout
mais le film spectaculaire ça veut dire
que l'on va à chaque fois s'est
préoccupé de sujets de société comme
celui là où est ce que pour vous un film
populaire ça peut être autre chose aussi
à un simple divertissement comme c'est
gratuit je me ce que l'idée l'idée même
du comique si c'est réussi c'est déjà
beaucoup quoi sont en trop s'occuper du
sujet
évidemment c'est plus ambitieux de faire
rire avec des sujets forts mais si c'est
réussi je crois que ces bases et chaque
fois pour plus fort ou et clip façon
l'un comme l'autre ils avaient envie de
le faire différents genres pas
simplement du comics vous avez
d'ailleurs prouvé que vous étiez capable
de faire autre chose oui bon on fait le
genre suivant les scénarios qu'on met en
route quoi que ce soit les histoires qui
nous intéresse mais y'a pas un genre
spécial a fait on va vous en propose
beaucoup de scénarios et peut-être qu'au
bout d'un moment à force de faire
d'interpréter tel type de personnage on
ne vous propose que des scénarios qui
correspondent aux personnages que l'on a
déjà vue seraient toujours des périodes
comme ça effectivement ou quand on a
tourné un rôle clé ils on peut marquer
c'est vrai qu'il ya toujours une période
qui suit où on propose que ça quoi mais
vous quand même vous avez joué un
assassin psychopathe et vous gérard vous
avez été dans une étrange affaire un
personnage qui ne fait pas rire
est ce que vous avez envie de temps en
temps comme ça de vous rattraper dans le
dramatique
personnellement non personnellement non
parce que je crois qu'une journée où on
n'est plus aujourd'hui c'est une journée
foot us et j'ai envie de rire j'ai envie
de ré en travaillant j'ai envie
d'entendre les gens rire quand ils
voient les films dans lesquels on a la
chance d'être en concurrence les frères
pétard c'est pour moi une éclat tri
supplémentaires je n'avais pas connu
avant et donc plus ça ira plus j'irai
vers les films comiques et ça vous a pas
fait rire quand il a été question que le
film et a alerté m
peut-être là du tanit sont angoissés
parce que je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui
peut faire un film sur un sujet pareil
en incitant les gens à aller dans ce
sens-là dire le bon sens et encore une
fois raison et je crois que c'est cette
publicité qui a eu tout autour du film
je remercie tous les gens qu'ils ont
participé bon on voulait passer une
interview christian weisner mais je
pense que ça sert pas à grand chose
c'est pas que christophe ne faut pas
intéressant mais il devait répondre sur
le problème de la censure finalement
gérard lanvin a très bien répondu en
disant que la meilleure façon de parler
de ce film c'était peut-être d'avoir
lancé cet acte de censure et anti
kadhafi n'est pas incitatif parce que
quand on a vu ce film on se rend compte
que si on essaye de négocier un paquet
baird
on a vraiment du mal et que la
vieillesse des dealers est vraiment
dangereux
alors est ce que l'on comme l'autre
andouille ration une scène de théâtre
bien tout pas bon mois pour tout de
suite mais enfin j'ai ça dans un coin de
la tête lui et vous jure un mois c'est
un problème d' association de copains je
veux dire quand on trouvera une pièce
avec des potes à jouer je serais partant
pour le faire il faut il faut simplement
au maître sans eau
oui là il y en avait quelques uns déjà
avec vous la banda escaut toujours
mais on arrive finalement à près de dix
ans on se connaît depuis dix ou quinze
ans et finalement ce qui est formidable
c'est qu'aujourd'hui et ont tous fait
notre chemin à droite à gauche etc
aujourd'hui on est acteur et donc on se
retrouve fréquemment et c'est cette
formule atlantic rich enthousiasmant
c'est vrai merci beaucoup et on vous
souhaite beaucoup de succès le prochain
rendez vous